I am ashamed because I know what mr.
Trump is he is a racist he is a con man
and he is a cheat mr. Trump knew of and
directed the Trump Moscow negotiations
throughout the campaign and lied about
it he lied about it because he never
expected to win the questions have been
raised about whether I know of direct
evidence that mr. Trump or his campaign
colluded with Russia
I do not Michael Cohen eighty three
hundred miles away from Hanoi Vietnam as
we get ready for this summit here
testifying about a host of issues the
Trump campaign putting out a statement
today saying Michael Cohen is a felon a
disbarred lawyer a convicted perjurer
who lied in both Congress and the
special counsel now he offers what he
says is evidence but the only support
for that is his own testimony which has
proven before to be worthless this is
the same Michael Cohen who has admitted
that he lied to Congress previously why
did they even bother to swear him in
this time let's bring in our panel
Charles hurt opinion editor for The
Washington Times Marie harf is co-host
of Benson and harf on Fox News radio and
Washington Post columnist mark Tyson
okay mark your takeaway from today yeah
so this testimony was the bombshell that
didn't explode there was a there was a
lot of stuff that was embarrassing for
Donald Trump and most most most
embarrassing was his association with
Michael Cohen but but you know remember
before this testimony there was all this
speculation of it Michael Cohen had
recorded conversations with Donald Trump
that he had might have had recordings
about him talking about colluding with
Russia or knowing about the Trump Tower
meeting or telling him to lie to
Congress it turns out he didn't have any
of that he didn't have any evidence of
anything that was impeachable and in
fact some of the things he said were
actually exculpatory so you played that
clip at the beginning of the segment
where he said that Donald Trump didn't
expect to win he said elsewhere that he
he just treated the whole campaign as an
infomercial for for the Trump brand well
if that's the case that kind of
undermines the argument that the payoff
to stormy Daniels was a campaign fine
violation because it's only a crime if
he was doing it for to advance his
campaign if he was doing it to not
embarrass his wife are not to get the
first white not to find out that's
that's sleazy but it's not criminal
so you know actually Michael Cohen
provided its culpa Tory evidence that
Donald Trump really didn't commit a
campaign finance violation which i think
is kind of interested in have any
information on collusion when asked
about that numerous times numerous ways
but as to your point about the store
McDaniels payment and the other payment
that he said were retainers here's that
exchange with one of the congressman
congressman the President of the United
States thus wrote a personal check for
the payment of hush money as part of a
criminal scheme to violate campaign
finance laws the payments were designed
to be paid over the course of 12 months
and it was declared to be a retainer for
services the president directed
transactions in conspiracy with Alan
weiselberger
and his son Donald Trump jr. part of a
criminal conspiracy a financial fraud is
that your testimony today yes then
Murray he brought forward two different
checks both signed by the President as
president and he said that these were
part of that payment your thoughts on
that well when he also testified Brett
that the reason the president wanted him
to pay off stormy Daniels was explicitly
to impact the outcome of the election so
even if he didn't expect to win he was
trying to impact that but I think one of
the bigger more important things that we
heard today from Michael Cohen was his
testimony that he witnessed other
criminal behavior by the president that
the Southern District of New York is
currently looking into and therefore he
couldn't get into those details but he
opened the door to the fact that the
Southern District of New York the place
many people think actually holds more
legal jeopardy for the president that
they are looking into other possible
criminal acts I also think on the Russia
issue Brett when he talked about Roger
stone and WikiLeaks and Roger stone
giving the president
sup that WikiLeaks was going to be
releasing damaging emails that doesn't
answer questions but it I think it
actually opens the door to even more
questions about what else Donald Trump
discussed with Roger stone about
WikiLeaks we don't know yeah I think I
think Roger stone had tweeted something
out the week before anyway Charlie your
your thoughts on this I mean the whole
thing was it was incredibly entertaining
it was a little bit like that all three
episodes of The Godfather on a nice cold
rainy day and you could sort of sit in
the inside and be entertained but you
know in all seriousness you know this is
a guy who says Donald Trump is a racist
is a conman he hates America
and yet he worked for him for ten years
and and and and obviously you know the
his whole record for for veracity around
here is not all that great
my favorite miss truth of the day was
when he claimed that the reason that
that he had decided to flip is because
of his you know calling of his
conscience and he wanted to clear
everything up no the reason that he
flipped is because his office got raided
and the reason that he's going to jail
is not because of these campaigns
suppose in campaign finance violations
which by the way the last person on
earth that I would get any legal advice
from especially on federal campaign
finance laws is Michael D Cohen he's not
who I'm gonna go to for that but the
book but I think I said no no but I
think it's very important to remember
that that of course you know those
violate what he's going to jail for is
defraud on his taxes and defrauding in
his taxi medallion business yeah he also
said he didn't want a White House job
and there was a lot of evidence even the
Southern District of New York put it in
the filing that he really wanted to be
at the White House
all right here's Jim Jordan from our
interview earlier about his take on the
whole thing last week Tom Styer mega
donor for the Democrats was in Jerry
Nadler SH district organizing a town
hall meeting to persuade mr. Nadler to
go ahead and move ahead with impeachment
two nights ago Tom Steyer was in
Baltimore in chairman Cummings district
organizing a town hall encouraging his
constituents to push chairman Cummings
to
ahead with impeachment that's what this
thing was about today you know mark
these hearings are always a bit
frustrating to watch the questioning not
going after the substance and a lot of
speechifying obviously Republicans
decided they were going to spend their
time to try to reduce or take away any
credibility that that Cohen had but your
thoughts on on their strategy well
taking away Crohn's Cohen's credibility
is low hanging hard to do but I'll tell
you I mean they do have a point not just
about Cohen's credibility but about the
Democrats as credibility and having this
hearing I mean the fact is that to have
this hearing on this day when you're in
Vietnam when the president is Vietnam in
Vietnam meeting with Kim jong-un trying
to focus on the new denuclearization of
the Korean Peninsula which is possibly
the most important national security
issue facing our country and both sides
everybody whether you're Republican or
Democrat has an interest in him
succeeding to have specifically chosen
this day in order to have it didn't work
because of the time difference but do
they wanted to have a split screen you
know is it's it's unpatriotic and I
think Americans saw that well we're
going to take your cue and talk about
Hanoi panel thank you very much our
panel here in Hanoi with some experts